so i've been watching this crazy  documentary series the history of home  and i've been learning about what  people's houses used to be like  everybody slept in the same room all the  cooking was done in the same room all of  the  reproduction was done in the same room  and the air quality was just atrocious  because people were using wood fires to  cook and to keep warm  in the same room that they were sleeping  all night it's a crazy series the  history of home i watched it on  curiosity stream curiosity stream is  awesome it's like  netflix or hulu but only for  documentaries  so their documentary selection is just  unbelievable they've got all the new  stuff series  documentaries economics politics  anything you could be interested in my  link in the description gives you access  for just 15 bucks a year it's like a  dollar 25 a month curiositystream.com  david